but everyone was like on it like all
right you gonna be the dog all right I'm
gonna do this like I'm going to work
today you know what did what did it
teach you about life you think
sometimes your homies just want to kiss
you
that's true that's so true
[Music]
welcome back to another
awesome episode of the careful boys hey
where we're currently
off the Record anybody ever say anything
wait a minute yeah Twitter's now X can I
can't uh can we do an unboxing of a
thing real fast yeah an unboxing where's
that somebody sent this to us and I
think you're gonna like it a lot it's
not even a box do you know what it is
yes you want to guess what it is based
off the shape it's for Bart the way
you're feeling it I want you to guess
what US you need a knife or something
the clothes but don't but be careful
when you if you're slicing it is it
close oh no be careful does it feel like
fabric you guys want to guess what it is
be really careful if you're gonna cut
okay I felt like it was closed for
somebody I think it's a puppy Hey look
look at that it's a dead puppy puppy
it's like some sort of like fleece
material where's the carpet it's the rug
you posted about it what rug I actually
follow us wow good job
yo this is sick this is gonna be so late
it's a JK rug the cameras never catch
the floor in here so it doesn't matter
dude why do I even wear I wear woo pants
why
dude Bart loves rugs so this is really
cool they made a JK rug yeah dude how do
you know I like Rooks I know what you
like dude that is from raw rugs
[Music]
thank you
so cool
[Music]
you guys want to hang it well it's
better than the motor oil Texaco
lubricates perfectly signed yeah we
should steam it we could steam it so
it's nice and straight and then we can
hang it somewhere this is cool man what
did you just wear to I don't know but
all right thank you raw rugs thank you
thank you so much Joe's gonna show you
his Ninja Turtles now because you gave
us a gift out of anything so he's gonna
go find his Ninja Turtles and say he
can't find it
wrong you don't want to hang it what the
[__] team at first it's too wrinkly oh
that's [__] tight dude that looks
like dope quality yeah that's really
good it's super thick I think it'll show
really where it's really really behind
us right there by the drums it was
really thick yeah I want to feel it yeah
it definitely need a steam now you're
not nobody's ever going to see it ever
dude I don't want to step on this it's
so nice yeah no it's all white you gotta
hang it don't put it in the bathroom
even for a second put in the glass case
or it could fit on that purple keep it
for a second what you know that purple
wall like right above the stack of
waters probably fit back there too yeah
but dude who's gonna see that let's see
it and you guys see it you can't even
tell it's a rug at that distance then
I'll put it we'll put it here I can't
wait to do this office
thank you thank you thank you that's
amazing and if you have any amazing arts
and crafts and want to dedicate a
shitload of your time and skills to us
please yeah and it's a great way to just
get free promotion because you know if
you guys want
you know people to buy your products is
probably just genius move
that was the best deal
for you what games did you play as a kid
that helped you in your opinion really
learn about life oh that's a good
question fight to get out of the room
fight to get out of them that's the
classic game what game is that it's it's
called Fight to get out of the room so
like all we do is we just lock the door
and then if you're the last one out
you're gay
so everyone's just trying to not be the
last one such a 90s game
in our school how long are you gay for I
think for the rest of your life okay and
then we'll have to register with the
Democratic National Party no one wants
to be gay so everyone's trying to rush
out of the room huh but what it taught
me
is that the first person to the to the
door is not necessarily the first one
out oh
cause you're in the worst position by
getting there first because people will
drag you because everyone will pull you
back and then you end up in the back and
it's usually like the third or fourth
guy that gets out first has it ever been
a moment where the last person comes out
and goes all right now I gotta make out
with you yeah or do they just get
married to a man immediately
it wasn't legal then so we couldn't oh I
said damn good point I had a friend when
we played house he always wanted to be
the wife and I was like that's
interesting because we usually want to
be the brother or the dad or the dog
only brothers and wives like you don't
assume the role of a girl even when
you're pretending right but he always
wanted to be the wife that's cool and
then later we find out that he came out
of the closet and he was you know he
became gay or he was always gay we
didn't ever do married couple things
with him in the game yeah the husband
like sometimes we I mean everyone would
play house he'd rotate different roles
and I remember like taking him to work
and then he [__] kissed me on the
cheek and played the role because we're
I mean he's the wife right so because my
brother would fix all these cars and we
would just have like cars all over my
[__] driveway whatever and then so
I'm just pretending and taking him to
work and goes okay see you see you at uh
see you later honey and then like like
he kissed me and then but he's my wife
yeah of course it's fine because he's
your wife yeah he's going to keep going
more details but no one we didn't even
think about like we were just like yeah
he's I don't know he likes to play that
all the time we're like seven or six
would he watch Kevin Costner movies and
get all excited
on that era I think Kevin Costner was
like the hot guy oh yeah dude it was
like him and Mel Gibbons right
[Laughter]
yeah all the chicks were hot for them
right yeah
I feel like playing pretendo was one of
my [__] favorite things to do like
whether you're like just doing like
mimicking adults like working yeah like
it's just acting right taika just
entered into this face as my favorite
phase because now he leaves me alone for
an hour and he's just pretending the
whole time because before he constantly
needs you right because he's like a baby
yeah but now he's entering his face
where he can imagine and he can play and
then like he just goes in his room and I
just hear
he never did
I think you have to get to a certain age
before you start like your imagination
takes over and then so now he can go
into his room and he is just preoccupied
for like a whole hour by himself and I'm
like yes some peace and you know what
probably happened is he meant his
imaginary friend and it's a [__]
ghost dude good okay give me some peace
get a ghost
yeah I remember like when we're on the
playground and some [__] stranger ass
kids would pull up and they'll be like
you guys want to play pretend and we'll
be like oh [__] game on dude pretend and
then like everyone knew how to play
house or everyone knew how to play like
okay we're working or whatever it is
yeah and then like you just make up the
game as you go and I was like that's
[__] sick I think those were this
it's like self-taught improv kind of
yeah but everyone was like on it like
all right you gonna be the dog all right
I'm gonna do this like I'm going to work
today you know what did what did it
teach you about life you think
sometimes your homies just want to kiss
you
that's true that's true that's so true
and then you go you just gotta you know
just pay attention yeah
let's be real though the true homies
don't want to kiss you yeah yeah that's
true he was a nice guy he was a nice
person
kind of shady dude kind of shady can't
really trust him yeah don't trigger your
motives or else you're not a real friend
that's true you never played like like
rough housing games when you were a kid
me and my sister we used to play
um speed
I don't know like uh well you'd act like
Keanu Reeves what like if you if you go
under a speed you're dead yeah like we
would play we'd like pretend to play it
on uh on like like uh car rides what you
pretend to play Speed what's that so
you're just playing pretend yeah just
playing pretend how do you play it it's
a variation of what you I'm trying to
remember are you deflecting on your
speed story no no I just thought it was
funny
so what the how did we play speed we
want to play right we would act like the
car can't go under a certain yeah like I
just I'm trying to think about it
actually were you Sandra Bullock yeah I
think I was Sandra dude
um no I think we were just me and my
sisters would like just pretend that
like we can't have the car go under 60
so you just rip dialogue and there'd be
moments in the car would be like
everybody get on the right side yeah
yeah yeah yeah like I forgot what we
would cholo with the gun show up to
they're like we just had a I remember my
mom used to have like a a Windstar van
and we would like when we would drive to
somewhere far we would [__] around and
pretend a place because we would watch
speed did your dad work on speed I think
he did actually your dad did the sound
for Speed yeah then you did this not for
Speed so we would just pretend to play
Speed is your sister like pop quiz Hot
Shot
we pretend to be on the phone like what
we needed that's right we give you a
hostage or whatever remember in the
beginning of the movie or I think Dennis
uh Hopper keeps on saying Pop Quiz
Hotshot and then at the end of the movie
Kiana's like pop quiz Hot Shot
that's a [__] class shaved head white
T-shirt I feel like playing like you
know at that age you learn a lot about
um how not every like some like how
people cheat how they like play unfair
oh for sure but then like even freeze
tag no yeah people be [__] cheating
and then you're like okay no matter what
every single time you play this game so
someone's gonna cheat today's video is
brought to you by DraftKings college
football fans are you ready for week one
DraftKings sports book is hooking you up
with a can't miss offer to start the
season strong this week new customers
can bet just five dollars on college
football and score two hundred dollars
in bonus bets instantly anything can
happen in college football your team can
go from unranked to Dynasty mode in just
a few years change comes fast the only
thing that's a lock is the great offers
from draftking Sportsbook life is more
fun when you're in on the action
download the draftking Sportsbook app
now and use the code off the Record new
customers can score 200 in bonus bets
instantly when they bet just 5 five
dollars on college football only in
draftking Sportsbook with code off the
Record the crown is yours do you have a
problem call 1-800 Gamma or visit
www.1800.net in New York call 8778
h-o-p-e-n-y or text h-o-p-e-n-y hey
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 7897 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort 21
plus age varies by jurisdiction boy in
Ontario ccdkng.com football for
eligibility terms and responsible gaming
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply yeah oh and then or
you'll know the ones that always like
never die or like you're playing war and
they'll be like oh no no no like you
shot me but I went like this and then
the bullet went through yeah and then
they never [__] die and you're like I
don't want to play this with this guy
you guys ever play play with the Power
Pad yeah for NES for NES no so so there
was like this pad and I had like a bunch
of circles on it and if you you could
play this track in this track and field
yeah and like when you're running the
characters running because it's like
moving being as fast as you are oh tight
I remember playing against my little
brothers all my both of my brothers are
younger than me by three years so like
my youngest brother Kenny's like seven
years on younger than me or whatever and
that doesn't add up like yeah like seven
years just about I think and then um so
we we would play this game and but both
of them didn't understand that when we
do the long jump game I would run on the
on the track I jump off the mat and then
my character is like and he's like
flying like Superman across the whole
house and then I jumped back on just
before the end so he doesn't fall over
yeah and then my other brother like
jumps and he just goes jump down up down
like because he just doesn't know what
I'm doing yeah yeah and I'm cleaning
their [__] clock and I don't want the
best I didn't care yeah I would just
beat them but but I couldn't just beat
them I had to destroy them but he would
just never tell them why yeah I'm just
like I'm like well my guy just went way
farther because I jumped way higher than
you and they're all watching the TV to
see when he comes out exactly they don't
know because they're excited they're
like like whoa how come he's jumping so
high yeah yeah what's the secret that
game is amazing I feel like that was
huge that's less than the idea of even
like taking your Nintendo or your
PlayStation and getting mods on them or
game sharks or games just the idea that
there were loopholes to like break rules
in order to like get high scores so cool
I feel like that was a real lesson in
life like I wasn't that deep ever works
the way the rule of the game is there's
always a hack or a cheat or a loophole
yeah there's always a code and if you
understood how to break that then you're
really winning you're not cheating
you're winning I remember when I was a
kid I used to do that with video games
and then get bored immediately I would
get all the cheat codes I'll play it
I'll be like 100 yeah yeah and I just
turn it off after like an hour I ruined
the Sims with that I got the infinite
money hack oh yeah it was boring as [__]
yeah I remember a lot of games being
based on violence yeah like you know
like like slug bug what's like to see
like Volkswagen oh yeah someone just
sucks you or like dead arm like you just
sock each other because there has to be
a negative consequence that's boys games
man bloody knuckles quarters remember
[__] quarters on the table scene
where you're like what's this one called
white power
like you kids still play those games
because it was just random acts of
violence no I don't think so I feel like
a parent will complain and actually it's
called bullying now dude when we were in
middle school we did the Midwest they do
at middle school we used to play this
game called uh well they called it I
didn't call it this they called it this
they call it smear the queer you guys
know what that came wow Nick dude I'm a
world champion how do you play that so
it'll be like kill the game
it was uh you just throw a football in
the middle of the field it's like 20
dudes whoever picks up the football has
to make it to the other end zone and
everyone just has to smash that guy oh
[__] why would anyone want to pick up
the football because it was just like a
thrill like I'm gonna be the guy that
could [__] do it it's Alpha [__] I'm
I'm the [__] I use my pure will to
get to the other end and what did that
teach you it taught you that [__] if
there's a will there's a way baby you
know what I mean like some and sometimes
when you pick up that ball and you're
just getting smashed out it's fine but
you just pick it back up I feel like at
that age
it also teaches you like uh where people
are in the pack you know what some
people would consistently stand out and
be like dude that guy's good at this
game you know what I mean you all like
Jamal and you'd be like no because we
had we had in fourth grade Jamal we all
know Jamal that was the first Chinese uh
I think so yeah there's a Cambodian
Chinese cattle we had a Jamal Mash bird
and I remember this is one when you
first started going like wait a second
there's something special about this guy
you got Nitro in your boots this guy
yeah you got nitrons this [__] turbo
at his caps
I was just like this is this is
something else but then you'd watch a
kid get props if they like made it and
then you'd be like oh dang I want a
props but you never understood that
concept before you know what I mean and
I had asthma so I'm trying to keep up
with Jamal but doesn't really work dude
I play you ever put Four's lava [__]
yeah floors lava taught me to just keep
moving just don't look back
that's what I found out [__] Tiger's
a cheating ass [__] when I play
floors lava with them all right because
like floors lava and then then I might
see him stepping on living room oh no
that's ocean now
hitting rules at the last minute man
drowning them tiger you're drowning
being a guilty Catholic [__] made me
like I would call myself out it's like
my ah I touched it I'm dead
it's all over pissed about it all over
I'm angry because I I know I can't cheat
because God's watching me
like I watch I love watching Tycoon like
his cousins play because you see all the
[__] cheating like they're playing
tag right I tagged you and you clearly
didn't even you didn't even touch them
yeah I attacked no you didn't yeah you
did and they're like this and I'm like
damn this cheating starts early you
gotta beat it out of them you know hide
and sock was funny hiding socks so when
you find the guy you finally you suck
the [__] out of him yo hide and seek was
one of my favorite games I did also
learn from hide and seek like how were
people's limits are
yeah
[Music]
some people's like this you went to the
next city they said people are like this
and they're like okay like like where
people are how far people are down ago
some people are down to [__] climb on
the roof get in the chimney some people
are down to [__] dig a hole in the
ground cover themselves up like you see
like oh wait this is that guy this guy's
like uh he's playing in the Marines for
sure this guy's a quarter Asser this
guy's [__] 200 percenter yeah you're
like oh this is crazy this guy jumping
the neighbor's lawn yeah people will go
to that length and then you find out
when people go really far then it's
almost being you're also lame like
there's a sweet spot yeah like when they
leave yeah if a person comes with the
[__] like brick house t-shirt so that
he can Mash into the brick house you're
like oh this guy's like that's not lame
[__] playing like pogs and Slammers
oh yeah I feel like that was the first
that's like gamble I was like trading
yeah gambling and training I feel like
gambling was also marbles back in the
day but like pogs and slams that's when
you would really see like damn that's
where did you get that sandwich like I
got to set the swap me it's like well
I'll trade you this much red like no
this much like no I want that from you
it's like no I'm not giving you know
what I mean like really starting to
learn what you valued even though
they're really all the same things my
first lesson in scam getting scammed was
through pogs because I had a bunch of
Slammers and then um this guy wanted one
of them
and he goes uh I'll give you I'll trade
you like some pogs for that and I was
like nah not you can't even give me
enough pogs and whatever he goes I'll
give you a hundred pops and I was like
[__] a hundred pogs that sounds like a
lot right so I was like all right for
sure let's do it and then they started
busting up and he started giving me the
dirtiest most [__] up pop that he
didn't want and then they were like hey
you said a hundred and then I'm just
sitting there going
no and they put it back out I was like I
don't want it anymore they're like no no
you already said yes you already said
yes and then I was like [__] and then
one of his other buddies was like with
your Slammer he could win a hundred pogs
now and I was like oh why why did I
agree and that's when I was like I gotta
be careful with the words and be
specific with the deal yeah dude
rights he gave me like a hundred it was
like peeling the graphics not even and I
gave him a pristine ass Slammer because
I imagined like brand new pogs 100 brand
new ones for that Slammer you gotta say
show me the pogs first that's a real
life lesson dude but yeah and I couldn't
go back on it and I was begging them I
was like please like I didn't know
that's what was gonna happen and he goes
nope we already agreed and I'm like that
guy's a sheisty [__] yeah definitely
more effective lesson than the [__]
guy who shows it with a brick wall
t-shirt yeah I like how the brick wall
t-shirts like is like a hat yeah I was a
third grader and I can't see his head or
his arm it's also good you experience
that young because there's people that
get [__] sheisted by timeshares and
[__] like when they're like 20 or 30. oh
yeah it's good that these things happen
to you young yeah yeah and I mean like
was it bullying like I made a deal right
and then yeah he did kind of fool me was
he an older kid they were laughing at me
yeah but I actually took responsibility
because I said yeah I did agree and I
try to do a take back you know I try to
do a please like I didn't know like did
he say no take backs at the beginning
yeah if he said no it's over nah but he
was like you already said yes and I was
like [__] it that feels a healthy
skepticism and he was at the same grades
I was scared of him and his buddies so I
was like [__] but you know he did take
it the strong armed you yeah I learned
that a lot of kids don't really play the
games they like to collect the [__] out
of stuff like I never played the Pokemon
card game but I collected those things
yeah that's fine never [__] played it
one time ever really not really I played
it once and I hated it that was boring
it's almost too nerdy to play it yeah
what did you get to do like add a bunch
of math and [__] like who wants to do
that yeah dude [__] that same with magic
the Gathering some people just collected
the cards [__] off dude I love magic did
you play it yeah I did by the way in the
magic the Gathering they recently did
collab with the Lord of the Rings out of
all the cards they made only one of one
uh uh pop ring of power and it's like
hologram and stuff this guy who pulled
it just sold his post alone for two
million dollars yeah
we're gonna do that article tomorrow but
I guess you ruined it
leave that in
foreign